thank you very much for joining us we
begin this NewsHour with the latest
efforts to restore ties between Iran and
Saudi Arabia the two countries have
announced plans for their foreign
ministers to meet Iran's Hussein Amir
abdullahian has proposed three locations
for the talks with the Saudi counterpart
Prince Faisal bin Farhan it comes after
they reach an agreement to mend a
seven-year Rift earlier this month let's
go live to our correspondente Iran Ali
Hashem Ali so another important step
towards re-establishing relations
between Saudi Arabia and Iran tell us
more about what was said today
there's actually more development the
Iranian president Ibrahim raisi
announced through his uh one of his
aides that King Salman of Saudi Arabia
sent him an invitation to visit Riordan
this is actually a big development
um raisi accepted the invitation he said
he's going to work on boosting relations
between the two countries now if we go
back to what Hussein said in the process
that we attended today in Tehran he also
stressed that both countries right now
are exchanging technical teams in order
to inspect the embassies in Riyadh and
in Tehran and see whether they're ready
for both missions to be deployed there
also he spoke about the attempts as you
said in the in the news copy that to to
meet the Iranians suggested according to
Abdullahi on three locations for the
meeting and what it was really
quite important that The Exchange took
place now through the Swiss Embassy and
not through the Chinese and this could
kind of indicate that there are several
channels between the Iranians and the
Saudis right now and Ali separately Iran
and Iraq have signed a joint Security
deal in Baghdad how significant this is
well this is very significant that
especially if we take into consideration
what happened during the past months
Iranians were bombarding the northern uh
territories of Iraq because of several
Iranian Kurdish separatists separated
groups that are functioning in that area
so Ali shamhani the Secretary of Iran's
Supreme National Security Council went
today to Iraq met Iraqi officials and it
was this agreement that they reached
actually in the Presa Hussein
also addressed this treaty
we agreed to form a national security
committee that included security and
legal representatives from the federal
government of Iraq the government of
Kurdistan in Northern Iraq and Iran a
security document for the first time has
been prepared and ready to be signed by
both countries previously there were
other documents with Northern Iraq only
there is full and well-studied
coordination in this regard between the
two countries through different
political and security committees
it's yet now to see whether this
agreement between Iraq and Iran is going
to have its impact on the region mainly
on the northern region of Iraq after all
these months of uh tension
um this is all what we have from Tehran
on uh Amir Abdullah thank you very much
for the rally Hashem live in Iran's
Capital Tehran